il avait lié la prime des managers au
retrait des produits j'ai vu des cas où
les managers
ne voulait pas
retirer le produit du marché même si le
produit était en violation avec les
normes de sécurité des aliments pendant
dix ans elle dit avoir alerté plusieurs
fois sa hiérarchie de dysfonctionnements
en vain j'étais dans une usine et j'ai
pose une question comment ça se fait que
des ouvriers rentrer avec leurs
vêtements de travail dans les toilettes
et là c'était la foudre qui s'est
abattue sur moi
pourquoi tu pose cette question tu
comprends pas business yasmine a
finalement été licencié par le groupe
nestlé officiellement pour divergences
d'opinion dans la gestion de la sécurité
des aliments
voilà oui valérie ce documentaire était
assez édifiant effectivement entre donc
pendant dix ans cette jeune femme
s'attache cette dame alerte est
officiellement c'est pour divergences
d'opinion et on apprend aussi dans le
documentaire qu'en 2015 l'équipe de
nettoyage de nuit est supprimée et elle
n'avait pas supprimé juste comme ça ex
nihilo à les supprimer pour être
remplacé par un créneau de production
c'est donc bien que on a remplacé par de
la production par pas de la productivité
au détriment de la sécurité donc c'est
une action volontaire donc ça roule
vraiment des questions la responsable tu
vas devoir n'est pas la seule à avoir
alerté la direction puisque il ya un
ancien salarié qui a lui aussi tenté de
se faire entendre en prévenant ses
supérieurs et en publiant des photos sur
les réseaux sociaux regarde un salarié
avait même tenté d'alerter en postant
sur internet des photos de la chaîne de
fabrication
c'était des boules de nourriture qui
restait à certains endroits pendant
plusieurs jours plusieurs semaines par
exemple dans des bacs de rattrapage de
sauce vous pouvez retrouver des fois
certains cas des mégots de cigarettes là
où la farine est envoyé sur les tapis
pour pâques lac la pâte colle et bah y
avait des défaire de farine qui
pouvaient tomber régulièrement et la
plupart des gens ne se lavaient pas les
mains ou même en revenant des toilettes
ne savait pas les mains donc il y avait
une contamination croisée qui était
clair ça m'étonne que seuil eu
d'accident avant alors là c'est fou et
moustache ce qui est fou c'est que entre
l'ancien responsable de la sécurité
l'employé de lusine la marque savait
donc la marque à cacher et ça j'espère
que ce sera au coeur de l'enquète
l'information judiciaire parce que c'est
irresponsable de leur part à chaque fois
c'est la même chose un scandale chasse
l'autre mais là non il ya eu 70 familles
qu'on portait plainte ya eu deux morts
c'est pas possible quand on voit sa
série c'est la marque qui bat voilà
sûrement mission et vous engueuler pas
moyennant
des sommes tout le monde oui on le voit
dans le documentaire
cimentaire franchement moi je vois pas
comment ils peuvent ils peuvent s'en
sortir parce que ces cas très chaud on
comprend qu'ils ont eu un truc aussi il
ya quelques années aux états unis et là
il n'y a pas eu de procès parce qu'ils
ont payé les victimes pourquoi parce que
l'amérique l'asie mal payés je veux dire
la vérité il n'y aura rien là moi ça me
fait beaucoup de peine c'est que si la
marque dégringole cccc les salariés vont
se retrouver à la rue mais c'est vrai
que ça va mais pour toujours plus
anciens à l'habilité c'est ça la et le
jingle donné ce qu'ils ont fait à
l'heure c'est bien manger bien vivre les
parents qui ont perdu leurs enfants ils
sont très contents je voudrais qu'on
écoute le témoignage incroyable des
parents de l'ena le destin de la famille
a basculé le 14 février dernier
lorsqu'il décide de manger des pizzas
fraîcheur tous ensemble la somme s'il va
subir une très grave intoxication ou
avec des séquelles à peine dix matches
et là pour une consommation sam de
pizzas regarder ça
sophie a fait des pizzas pour un petit
dîner avec ses deux filles ou prend une
pizza nos congélateurs de la marque
fraîcheur de chez brittany et le
lendemain matin lena au réveil se plaint
d'avoir mal au ventre là je regarde en
fait elle avait de la diarrhée avec du
sang cinq minutes après elle tombe dans
les pommes samu urgences les nains et
finalement hospitalisées le verdict
tombe elle souffre du syndrome
hémolytique urinaire causée par une
bactérie ces toxines tueuse vont
endommager le cerveau de l'ena alors
qu'elle était en pleine santé les nains
est dans un état végétatif
elle est paralysée c'est le monde qui
s'écoule sur nous quoi tout simplement
ça a été très très dur c'est qu'elle
a regardé je vous dis c'est vrai qu'en
ces images elles sont terribles pour la
marque et c'est la première fois qu'on
voit des images aussi choquant donc on
se met forcément la place des familles
ont dit que ça aurait pu nous arriver à
tous soit notre famille et on a vraiment
l'impression effectivement que la marque
prenez des risques au détriment de la
santé des consommateurs et donc quelque
part parce qu'on pouvait croire au début
que c'était des cas isolés mais donc
quelque part que ce qui est arrivé était
presque inévitable et c'est ça qui est
terrible avec ce document pour l'instant
officiellement vous le savez deux
enfants ont perdu la vie à cause de ses
pizzas une vie déchirée bien sûr du jour
au lendemain pour les parents j'allais
avoir un témoignage bouleversant
des parents de nathan
leurs enfants mourir à l'hôpital en tout
inscrit sans se regarder
nathan avait 8 ans en quatorze jours la
bactérie avait atteint plusieurs organes
vitaux plus on allait attendre plus
encore ils allaient se déformer il avait
gonflé fallait qu'on prenne la décision
d'arrêter les machines dès que possible
on est une âme à médiapart on a fait
tout ce qu'on pouvait faire c'est une
décision que devient parent doit prendre
c'est pas dans l'ordre des choses en
fait on parle en son nom pour voir
mourir avant nous tu fais confiance à
une marque on
c'est pas n'importe qui ils font la pub
à la télé mais ce n'est c'est bien
manger bien vivre bravo
très très dur al témoignages de ses
parents où le témoignage est
bouleversant c'est qu'il est empli de
dignité et ils rêvent indicatif ils sont
pas dans la haine dans la violence il
exprime clairement comme ça et
effectivement ça fait froid dans le dos
parce que on se dit finalement que si la
marque avait entendu les avertissements
avant tout ça aurait peut être évité
avec bourg des comptes pour cette
famille mais c'est terrible tu es gentil
très très dur et c'est arrivé aux etats
unis c'est que très souvent les gens qui
consomment des pizzas pas cher d'un des
restaurants pas chers des gens qui n'ont
pas beaucoup d'argent donc idée rien ne
pourront pas beaucoup de défendre nous
prendrons pas de très bons avocats face
à des mastodontes comme ces boîtes là et
qu'ils s'en sortent souvent on a eu le
scandale de l'ehpad qui était horrible
parce qu'on a depuis tony là j'ai qu'une
trouille c'est que dans quelques mois à
coups de pognon tousart et avance à
venir serrer avance 1ere avance écrase à
nouveau ceux qui n'ont pas d'argent la
parade aux etats unis c'est horrible ce
que je vous dirais milliards a fallu que
cette pizza elle tue quelqu'un de 2,2 de
riches où deux puissants ou quelqu'un
qui puisse faire du bruit c'est ça ce
qui est horrible c'est que ces
souris pour cette famille d'accord ça ne
suffit pas on a mis brisé et il est il à
la maman de l'ena juste à bourillot qui
ont des séquelles aussi son calme
malgré cette énorme au scandale on
aurait pu penser que les réactions du
groupe soit à la hauteur pour ces
familles des chiens mais ce n'a pas été
le cas pour certains qui se sont vus
proposer en compensation des chèques
cadeau de 20 euros à la maison voilà
voilà
ce lien a été contacté par lui tony sa
fille mila a été hospitalisé après avoir
mangé une pizza de la marque aujourd'hui
elle va mieux mais ses parents restent
choqués notamment par l'attitude de but
ni et en appelle au service consommateur
du 8e ni elle m'a simplement demandé si
pour le bien de leur enquête ils
pouvaient accéder au dossier médical de
mon enfant né c'est oui une demande
illégale car le dossier est couvert par
le secret médical mais sonia va encore
avoir des nouvelles de buitoni pour
s'excuser du désagrément il m'envoie
chèque cadeau d'une valeur de 20 euros
balade dans plus de 800 enseignes tout
ce qu'ils avaient vécu ma fille ça
valait ferrero et désagréments j'espère
que c'était un mail automatique oui
en général kelly c d e mails qui sont
faits en espérant que les gens se
taisent après ça cc c'est ciblé sur la
dame tient on a fait une erreur avec
celles où personne on va essayer de la
faire taire s'est pas déclenchée parce
qu'ils n'ont pas et ça oui non non c'est
pour cette dame n'a pas d'argent ne
porte pas plainte et celles des communes
rien n'est laissé au hasard dans cette
mare rien tout est cloisonné au siège
quelques personnes décident rien et du
hasard rien ni d'excusés mais il ya
quand même marqué bonne nouvelle ce n'ya
donc je pense quand même qu'ils sont pas
cynique à ce point là je pense que c'est
je vois je n'arrive à l'histoire des
bonnes nouvelles sonia ou alors vraiment
la question c'est pas du mail
automatique ou pas automatique la
question c'est est ce que les
responsables de nestlé directeur chez fo
chefaillons j'en sais pas qui vous allez
voir les gens vous allez vous excuser en
personne sur les voitures
vous leur dites on sera avec vous non
mais d'asmara grille tarifaire tati
d'étouffer le dossier quand tu appelles
la personne la maman et que tu demandes
à avoir accès au dossier médical alors
qu'il sait pertinemment que normalement
c'est absolument interdit c'est qu'il ya
quelque chose de dense tout maroc on
essaie de faire est sûr mais ils veulent
faire ce qu'on a choisi états unis en
france mais ça va on se retrouve alors à
ma fiche mon livre on se retrouve dans
un homme n'y aura rien c'est vrai qu'un
avocat il ya un avocat qui
s'annonçait très ils vont tous la
responsable d'entrepôt à de trois mille
balles par maria luisa c'est nickel a
dit aux salariés nettoyer toi tu vas
prendre pour tout le monde et c'est on
va donner comme a dit mathieu on va
donner dans toute l'île parce que c'est
toi qui vas morfler pour tout le monde
et chefs d'entreprise à accepter les
thunes et c'est fini ça va se passer
comme ça dix ans d'essais des grosses
tendances ya une information judiciaire
quai ouvert ses blessures et homicides
involontaires on va voir jusqu'où ça va
aller
en prison c'est tous les gros bonnets
fortes ou s'il vous plaît sont pas tous
en même temps merci